Hi zusammen! Seid ihr bereit für die leckerste Haselnusscreme-Torte dieser Weeelt?
Ich schon, du Hamza?
[Hamza] Jaaaa!
Die ist sehr speziell: Sie besteht aus nur 6 Zutaten und ist extrem cremig von der Textur her
und ich muss auch sagen: anfängergeeignet, wirklich anfängergeeignet!
[Hamza] Leute die schmeckt echt heftig!
[Kiki] Die schmeckt hef-tig!
[Hamza] Sorry, ich hab dich jetzt unterbrochen!
Alles gut, alles gut!
Also, wir haben diese Haselnusscreme-Torte bzw. ich hab sie mal gemacht.
Das ist eine No Bake Torte, ich hab sie einfach gemacht.
Und in dem Video zu der Entstehung meiner Haselnusscreme, das kann ich euch gerne mal hier verlinken oder hier,
ich bin mir grad nicht sicher. Auf jeden Fall könnt ihr euch das gerne nochmal ansehen.
Da sieht man am Ende dann diese Torte, die ich eigentlich nur so ausprobiert hatte.
Und da haben ganz viele gefragt: "Wann kommt denn das Rezept dazu?" und jetzt kommt's!
Also ich fange direkt an. Die ganz genauen Angaben findet ihr unten in der Videobeschreibung, wie immer.
Ich fang an mit meinem Keksboden und da nehmt ihr euch jetzt z.B. Butterkekse oder Kakaobutterkekse
oder so wie ich das heute mache: Ich hab hier diese Karamellkekse.
Die kennt ihr mit Sicherheit alle. Die gibt's z.B. jetzt von Lotus. Die gibt's auch von Stereo, das ist so ein Dupe davon.
Da gebe ich jetzt erstmal was hier in meinen Mixer und lasse das erstmal fein... ja, zu kleinen Minikrümeln mixen!
[Hamza] Das wird der Boden?
[Kiki] Das wird der Boden, genau!
Jetzt kommt noch geschmolzene Butter dazu.
Das mach ich z.B. bei 390 Watt in der Mikrowelle für 1min, das geht immer ganz schnell.
Macht nicht den Fehler und geht hoch mit der Wattzahl, sonst platzt euch die Butter auf.
Wem ist das schon mal passiert? Mir auf jeden fall damals immer mal wieder!
[Hamza] Selbst mir ist es passiert!
[Kiki] Selbst dir, genau!
So. Jetzt gebe ich das hier rein, verrühre das kurz und dann kommt das auch schon direkt auf meine Tortenplatte.
Falls ihr wenig Platz im Kühlschrank habt, dann könnt ihr auch ein Cakeboard untendrunter legen
weil später wird der Boden schön fest und dann ist es gar kein Problem, ihn auf eine Tortenplatte zu transferieren.
Meinen Tortenring habe ich eingestellt auf 20cm.
Jetzt kommt die fluffige Haselnusscreme und dafür habe ich jetzt Sahne steif geschlagen.
Wichtig ist, dass die Sahne komplett kalt ist, also direkt aus dem Kühlschrank kommt
und ihr braucht kein Sahnefest! Ich hab das jetzt in der Küchenmaschine gemacht, das hat 2min gedauert.
Ihr könntet natürlich auch euer Handrührgerät benutzen.
Und die Sahne kommt jetzt ganz kurz an die Seite und in einer weiteren Schüssel habe ich Doppelrahmfrischkäse.
Einige schreiben bei anderen Rezepten z.B. "Mein Frischkäse schmeckt sehr salzig!"
Ich kenne auch Doppelrahmfrischkäse, der ist eher salzig und total trocken.
Ich benutze jetzt z.B. - Das ist jetzt keine bezahlte Werbung! - ich benutze jetzt Philadelphia.
Aber ihr könnt mir mal in die Kommentare schreiben, ob ihr noch weitere Firmen oder Marken kennt,
die auch nicht ganz so salzig schmecken und halt so ein bisschen cremiger sind.
Und da gebe ich jetzt meine Haselnusscreme rein.
Ich habe euch ja schon gesagt oder schon angeteasert:
Meine Haselnusscreme ist nicht nur ein Brotaufstrich sondern ihr könnt damit auch gut Rezepte machen und backen usw.
Und das Tolle ist: Die Creme wird halt ein bisschen fester wenn sie gekühlt wird.
Deshalb ist sie auch manchmal wenn sie bei euch Zuhause ankommt (das habe ich in vielen Stories gesehen), ein bisschen härter.
[Hamza] Gerade jetzt im Winter!
Grad jetzt im Winter weil's ja dann auch im Wagen von DHL etc. -
Also so ist sie jetzt bei mir auf Zimmertemperatur und je wärmer es ist, desto weicher wird sie.
So sieht's aus.
Und manchmal bildet sich auch ein Fettfilm oben und das ist nämlich das Fett aus den Haselnüssen.
So, jetzt gebe ich davon was zum Doppelrahmfrischkäse und dann rührt ihr das bitte nicht mit einem Schneebesen!
Ich nehm mir jetzt einen Teigschaber und dann rühre ich das ganz vorsichtig und nicht zu lang
damit der Frischkäse auch nicht so flüssig wird.
[Hamza] Boah ich freu mich schon ey!
Also ich weiß jetzt schon, dass du durchdrehen wirst!
Genauso wie dieser Teigschaber!
Anschließend sieben wir noch Puderzucker dazu und heben das ganz kurz unter.
Und an der Stelle nochmal ein wichtiger Hinweis: Unser Doppelrahmfrischkäse sollte kalt sein!
Ich hab die Packung wirklich gerade erst aus dem Kühlschrank geholt.
Und was auch wichtig ist: Wir dürfen nicht zu lange rühren,
deswegen nehme ich jetzt auch ungerne einen Schneebesen.
Also wirklich nur so kurz es geht!
Und ihr merkt auch, dass die Creme dann irgendwann anfängt, zu glänzen
und an der Stelle solltet ihr auch nicht mehr weiterrühren.
Vielleicht kannst du das gleich nochmal von Nahem zeigen Hamza!
Und im nächsten Schritt hebe ich auch schon die Sahne unter.
[Hamza] Yes, die glänzt echt!
[Kiki] Ja, die ist jetzt am Glänzen und weiter solltet ihr auch nicht rühren.
Jetzt in mehreren Schritten die Sahne unterheben.
Die Creme hat jetzt eigentlich nur 5-6min gedauert und sie ist schon fertig
und ich hab extra kein Sahnefest reingegeben.
Ich hab das ja vorab schon ausprobiert und ihr glaubt nicht, was für eine Konsistenz später -
[Hamza] Sehr cremig!
[Kiki] Extrem!
Also sie ist jetzt schon cremig aber eben noch nicht standfest und deswegen kommt gleich unsere längere Kühlzeit.
Und deswegen tut mir einen Gefallen:
Wenn ihr hier angekommen seid und die Creme ist in eurer Schüssel fertig und sie kommt gleich auf den Boden,
nehmt euch einen Löffel und probiert mal damit die Vorfreude umso größer ist!
[Hamza] Für mich auch?
[Kiki] Na klar!
[Hamza] Korrekt!
So, so, so himmlisch leicht! Hammer!
[Kiki] Boah! Meine Vorfreude, mein Level ist hier oben irgendwo!
[Hamza] Mmmh!
[Kiki] Krass oder?
[Hamza] Ja Mann, das isses!
[Kiki] Das isses, das isses!
[Hamza] Dieser Geschmack!
Also denkt an meine Worte: Probiert jetzt
Und dann werdet ihr einfach nur noch die Stunden zählen bis die Torte aus dem Kühlschrank kommt!
Und ich gebe jetzt die Creme einfach auf den Boden und streiche das schön glatt.
[Hamza] Die Vorfreude steigt!
Ja, mehr können wir jetzt gerade nicht tun denn unsere leckere, cremige Torte muss jetzt gekühlt werden.
Und während der Kühlzeit passiert jetzt folgendes:
Die Creme wird schön fest, sie sitzt. Sie wird auch ein bisschen luftiger.
Also sie ist ja schon sehr luftig und cremig aber die Konsistenz verändert sich halt nochmal nach den 6-8h.
Das hört sich immer viel an aber ihr könnt das auch gerne am Vortag vorbereiten!
Zum Beispiel ihr wollt sie Samstag anschneiden, dann macht sie einfach Freitag Abend schon
oder Freitag Morgen, ganz je nachdem, wie ihr Zeit habt.
[Hamza] Oder macht das morgens früh und dann abends isst man das!
[Kiki] Das wollt ich grad sagen! Richtig gut!
[Kiki] Also ihr könnt das z.B. morgens machen..
[Hamza] Ich pass gut auf!
Sagen wir mal ihr fangt um 10h an, Zubereitung dauert ja nur 20min wenn überhaupt
und dann könnt ihr die abends um 18h essen, also perfekt!
Wir sehen uns dann gleich wieder, dann zeige ich euch nämlich den leckeren Haselnuss-Guss!
Ich hab das Ganze jetzt schon vorbereitet.
Das Coole ist: Ich hab später 2 Torten! Die müssen wir natürlich noch verteilen, ne?
[Hamza] Eine gehört dir und eine mir!
[Kiki] Ja ok, so kann man's auch sehen!
Also meine Torte ist jetzt schön durchgekühlt und für den Guss kommt jetzt einfach nur noch die leckere Haselnusscreme on top!
So könnt ihr sie natürlich nicht verstreichen, sie muss erstmal geschmeidig und flüssiger werden.
Und dafür könnt ihr sie entweder in warmes Wasser geben für 1min ca.
oder in die Mikrowelle, das mach ich bei 600Watt für ca. 30 bis maximal 40 Sekunden.
Natürlich beides ohne Deckel!
Und dann hat sie eben so eine richtig schöne, flüssige Konsistenz,
die aber auch wiederum fester wird wenn ihr sie aushärten lasst bzw. kühlt.
Also die perfekte Haselnuss-Glasur!
Und jetzt wird's richtig pervers!
Jetzt kippe ich das einfach auf die Tortenoberfläche und verteil's dann.
So! Und jetzt ruhig schwenken und ein bisschen schütteln.
Ihr könnt jetzt solange die Glasur noch nicht fest geworden ist noch gehackte Haselnüsse oben drauf geben.
Das ist nur optional, ihr könnt ansonsten dekorieren, wie ihr möchtet!
Und die Glasur braucht ungefähr 20min zum Festwerden
oder ihr gebt sie einfach kurz in den Kühlschrank für 10-15min und dann könnt ihr auch schon anschneiden!
Ich benutze übrigens meinen Backformlöser damit ich mir auch an den Seiten nichts kaputt mache.
[Kiki] Ok Leute ich hab vergessen: Wir haben gar keinen Tasty Table mehr
aktuell weil wir einen Wasserschaden hatten!
[Kiki] Oh, hi!
[Hamza] Ich lad grad die Akkus auf!
*beide lachen*
[Kiki] Okay, Akkus sind aufgeladen. Hamza komm, ich brauch dich!
[Hamza] Ich komme, warte!
[Kiki] Das hier ist unsere Kaffee-Ecke, die ist ganz neu gegenüber von der Küche..
[Kiki] ..und ja, das ist mal so ein Ersatz aktuell!
[Kiki] Hast du ganz schön präsentiert!
[Hamza] So, soll ich probieren?
[Kiki] Ja, bitte probier!
[Hamza] Als ob ich nicht weiß wie er schmeckt, ich weiß wie er schmeckt!
[Kiki] Aber du hast ihn das letzte Mal vor 'nem Monat gegessen!
[Hamza] Letzte Mal war Weihnachten 26.12., genau!
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] So, ich probier's nochmal!
[Kiki] Okay, das sagt alles!
[Hamza] Ich weiß nicht, warum ich den Kuchen so liebe. Vielleicht liegt's einfach an unserer Haselnusscreme!
[Hamza] Aber Leute er schmeckt echt heftig! Sehr, sehr lecker!
[Hamza] Wir haben ja hier den Karamellkeksboden, der harmoniert so geil mit der Creme. Unglaublich!
[Hamza] Leute, das schmeckt echt gut. Macht's unbedingt nach. Ich bin verliebt!
[Kiki] Okay, das war ein schönes Schlusswort!
[Hamza] Kurz und knapp!
[Hamza] Von der Höhe könnte es 'nen Ticken kleiner sein aber der Cremeanteil schmeckt echt gut. Sehr, sehr gut!
[Kiki] Ja, das muss ich auch noch hinzufügen: Da ist echt viel Creme aber genau das ist ja das Leckere! Genau das ist es!
[Hamza] Hast du eigentlich Zucker reingemacht in die Creme?
[Kiki] Nur ein bisschen Puderzucker! Nur 50g auf den ganzen Kuchen!
[Hamza] Weil du hast ja die Haselnusscreme hier drin. Die ist ja eh schon süß, ne?
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Gut abgewogen!
[Hamza] So Leute, das war's! Ich esse hier fröhlich weiter.
[Hamza] Und ich mache jetzt Kikis Abschied einfach mal. *mit hoher Stimme* Tschüüss, eure Kiki!
[Kiki] Oh nein, nein, da hab ich einen Einwand!
[Hamza] Wieso?
[Kiki] Du musst beide Hände benutzen!
[Hamza] Ja aber ich hab Kuchen in der Hand!
[Kiki] Du musst den kurz abstellen und dann beide Hände benutzen!
[Hamza] Nee, ich leg den niemals ab!
[Hamza] Da kannst du lange warten!